(light dramatic jingle)
- Hello, Believe Nation, I
started the Mentor Me Series
with the goal to try
and hang around people
who've had a lot more success than us
and hopefully, by spending a
little more time with them,
some of their mindset,
their belief systems,
their way of thinking, seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today, we're going to learn
some of the very best advice
from some of the Forbes billionaires.
So every year, Forbes makes a list
of the richest people in the world.
Many of them are entrepreneurs
and I thought it'd be a fun idea
to take some of the very
best advice from the list
of the wealthiest, most
successful Forbes billionaires
to help us get stronger.
And as always, as you're
watching the video,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it as well
so other people can be inspired, too.
Enjoy.
(light inspirational music)
- When I started Microsoft,
I didn't think of it as all that risky.
I mean, I was so excited
about what we were doing.
It's true, I could have gone bankrupt
but, you know, I had a set of skills
that were highly employable and, in fact,
my parents were still willing
to let me go back to Harvard
and let me finish my
education if I wanted to.
- You've always got a job with me, Bill.
(laughing)
- And that thing that was scary to me
wasn't quitting and starting a company,
it was when I started hiring my friends
and they expected to be paid.
(laughing)
And then we had customers
who went bankrupt,
customers that I'd
counted on to come through
and so, then I got this
incredibly conservative approach
that I wanted to have
enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll,
even if we didn't get
any payments coming in.
And I'm almost true to
that the whole time.
We have about 10 billion now,
which is pretty much enough
for the next year.
(laughing)
Anyway, if you're going
to start a company,
it takes so much energy
that you better overcome
your feeling of risk.
I don't think that you, necessarily,
if you're going to start a company,
you should do it at the
start of your career.
I think there's a lot to be
said of working for a company,
learning how they do things.
If you're young, it's
hard to go least premises.
They made that hard for
me, you couldn't rent a car
when you were under 25 at the time,
so I was always taking
taxis to go see customers.
(audience laughing)
And people would say,
"We're going to have a
discussion at the bar."
Well, I couldn't go to the bar.
(audience laughing)
But you know, that's fun
because I'll tell you,
when people are first
skeptical and they go,
"This kid doesn't know anything."
Then, when you show them you've
really got a good product
and you know something,
they actually tend to go
overboard and they think,
"Whoa, you know, they know a lot.
"Let's really do an incredible
amount with these people."
So our youth, at least in this country,
was a huge asset for us once
we reached a certain threshold.
It is hard, it's hard to hire older people
because they'll be a
little bit conservative
about whether they should
come and take the risk
and it took three or four years
before we could go out into
the normal employment pool.
But those problems that
come with starting a firm,
you better think of those
as part of the pleasure,
part of the challenge, that
is part of the excitement.
- [Woman] I was just wondering,
what would you consider
to be the worst investment
that you've ever made?
(audience laughing)
- The worst investment I ever made?
Hmm, how long do you have?
(audience laughing)
- I've made some very bad ones
but that doesn't really bother me.
You know, it'd bother the shareholders
but that's another question.
(audience laughing)
You're going to make mistakes in life.
I mean, there's no question about it.
You don't want to make 'em on
the big decisions, you know,
who you marry and some things like that.
There's no way I'm going
to make a lot of business
and investment decisions
without making some mistakes.
I may try to minimize 'em.
I don't dwell on 'em at all.
I don't look back.
The biggest mistakes
are the ones that actually don't show up.
They're the mistakes of
omission rather than commission.
We never lost that much
money on any one investment.
But it's the things
that I knew enough to do
that I didn't do.
We have missed profits of as
much as 10 billion dollars
and things that I knew
enough to do and didn't do.
Now, the fact I didn't
buy Microsoft way back
is not a foregone opportunity
because I didn't know enough
to make that decision.
But there have been other investments
where I did know enough
to make the decision
and for one reason or another,
I either didn't do it at all
or I did it on a small scale.
I was sucking my thumb
when I should have been writing
checks, you know, basically.
(audience laughing)
And those don't show up.
There's no place where it
shows missed opportunities
but I've missed some big ones.
The triumphs in life are partly triumphs
because you know everything
isn't going to be a triumph
and I would never get
too hung up on mistakes.
I know a lot of people that
really agonize over them
and it just isn't worth it.
Tomorrow's another day
and you live it forward
and just go on to the next thing.
- We know from our past experiences
that big things start small.
You know, the biggest
oak starts from an acorn
and if you want to do anything new,
you've got to be willing
to let that acorn grow
into a little sapling and then,
finally, into a small tree
and maybe one day, it'll be
a big business on its own.
- And in fact, that's one of the mottoes
for one of your initiatives
and forgive my pronunciation
of the latin, Gradatim ferociter,
what does that mean to you?
- Well it means step-by-step ferociously
and it's the motto for Blue Origin.
And basically, you can't skip steps.
You have to put one foot
in front of the other.
Things take time.
There are no shortcuts.
But you want to do those steps with,
you know, passion and ferocity.
- The main thing is, when
you're starting something,
it's just kind of hard, you
need to be pretty headstrong
about it, where there are going
to be all these challenges
that come up and I think the
main thing that you need to do
is just not give up, right?
And kind of know what you want to do
and the best entrepreneurs who I've met
don't really start
companies because their goal
is to build a company, they do it
because they want to make
a change in the world
and help people and I think, if
you kind of stay true to that,
and if you just focus on powering through,
no matter what the challenges are
that will inevitably come up in your path,
then you'll find that
there are lots of tools
that are available and a lot of people
who will help you build
what you're building.
- Think things out for yourself.
Come to your own judgements.
Don't simply conform to
conventional ways of thinking,
conventional ways of dressing,
conventional ways of acting.
A lot of things are based on fashion.
Even morality, at times,
is based on fashion.
Slavery was once considered
not to be immoral.
People are shocked that the
Ancient Greeks had slaves,
that we had slavery in
this country as recently
as 130, 140 years ago.
So, there are moral values,
you have to really go back
to first principles and think
things out for yourself,
whether they're scientific
principles or moral principles
or business ideas or product ideas,
you have to think things out for yourself.
- I believe that the family
and the personal life
in business or professional life
is not totally compatible, it's necessary.
You will have a better professional life
with a good personal life and family life
than if you don't have a good
personal life and family life.
I don't understand the
contrary and it's very clear
that the good personal
life makes you stronger,
you are stronger for the challenges,
you are working, I don't
believe in working the hours
of 16 hours or 14 hours.
When you work too much,
it's because your job
is beyond you.
You are not controlling, you
are not doing good, your job.
If you need to be 15 hours, 16 hours,
it's because you are not organized,
that you don't have delegation
of your responsibilities
and I don't believe in any
business, in any activity,
you need to work 15 or 16 hours
and you don't have time for yourself
or for your family or for anyone.
- When I graduated from
universities, and before I,
you know, for three years I
tried for in the universities,
so applied jobs for thirty
times, got rejected.
I went for a place, they
said, "No, you're not good."
I went to even the KFC,
when KFC came to China,
came to our city,
(audience laughing)
24 people went for the job.
23 people were accepted,
I was the only guy.
(audience laughing)
And we went for police, five people,
four of them accepted,
I was the only guy that
did not receive it.
So to me, being turned down, rejected,
oh by the way, I told
you I applied for Harvard
for 10 times, rejected.
(audience laughing)
I know I'll be rejected--
- They're sorry now.
10 times, your wrote them
and said "I'd like to come to Harvard."
- Yeah, and then I told myself,
"Someday, I should go teach there, buddy."
(audience laughing)
- Now, if you want to make a quick buck,
you can do it a lot of different ways.
You can cheat somebody, you
can misrepresent something,
you can go manipulate the political system
to get an advantage, but if
you want to be successful
over a long period of time,
I believe you need to focus first of all
on creating value for others.
And I've had people, "Oh,
that's naive, that's utopian."
No, it isn't, because
why will the customers
want to pay you anything
over a long period
unless you're creating value for them?
Why would your employees
want to work for you
or if they did, they didn't
have any alternative,
why do they want to
give their best efforts?
Why do they want to get excited?
Why would they wake up
at night with ideas?
If you're in a community,
a plant in a community,
unless you're creating
value for that community,
why would the community want you there?
If you're polluting and hurting people
and not contributing
anything to the community,
so long term success
starts with being dedicated
to creating value for others.
It's not altruism, my whole philosophy
is to have a system of mutual benefit,
where both parties gain, a
society based on win-win.
- The only thing that you can control
that influences success in
life is how hard you work,
how honest you are and how
well you deal with others.
You can control, those are
variables, those variables.
You can't control how lucky you are,
although, the more you
work, the luckier you get.
You have no influence on the
intellectual capabilities
that God did or did not give you
but you can work as hard as possible,
you can be scrupulously
honest so people respect you
and you can get along with others
because nobody does
anything by themselves.
- Did you have to pay a
price, though, you personally?
- Well, I think that
everything is an either/or.
There is a price in everything.
You can study or you can go out and play.
You can defer to others or
you can try to hog the credit.
You can be honest and
suffer the consequences
or you can lie, cheat, and steal
and short-term, maybe even
advance but long-term,
you are better off if you work harder.
You are better off if you're honest
and you are better off
if you give others credit
and get them to help you, by helping them.
- What do you tell others who
try to strike that balance?
Between family and work
and volunteer efforts
and everything else?
- Well, you have to answer
and either/or is invariably yes,
you can't go all in one direction.
You cannot walk away from
your family for your career.
On the other hand, if you
walk away from your career
for your family, you're
not going to have the money
to support the family and
parents, all the time,
are making those kinds of choices
between career and family,
they do some of both
and you try to blend the two
and that may not be the perfect answer
but that's a practical answer
that I've always told young people
when they go off to
college, you have to study
and you have to get good grades
but you certainly should
have a good time, as well.
Because that's part of
your growing up experience
and there's no point in leading
life to suffer all the time,
you want to enjoy life as
well as the next person.
So, it's some balance,
some blend between the two.
- I want to talk about
dreams for a second.
And in my case, we're
literally in a dream.
When I was in college, I was
sure that I'd been admitted
by a clerical error,
probably a computer error.
(audience laughing)
And because of that,
I had an irrational fear
I'd be sent home on the bus.
The Sergei's here knows this is true.
(audience laughing)
But it turns out, because of that anxiety,
I woke up literally with a dream
and it was kind of a strange dream.
It went like, I think I
can download the entire web
onto some old computers
that were lying around.
(audience laughing)
And that would probably seem
pretty crazy to most people
but I stayed up a couple hours
in the middle of the night
doing some math and it seemed
actually pretty plausible.
Well, assuming you actually
didn't keep any of the webpages,
you only kept the links.
And then, started to figure
out, given all that data,
I thought it would take a couple of weeks
and I told my advisor that and
he just sort of laughed at me
and it of course took a year or two.
But at the end of that, we
had a way to rank webpages
and no thoughts to search it all,
but eventually, search entered the picture
and you know the rest
and that became Google.
(audience applauding)
So I hope to encourage everyone
to follow their dreams.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed, I'd love to know,
what did you think of this
video, did you enjoy it?
Did you learn from it?
What was your favorite clip and
what was the biggest message
that you took from this video?
What are you going to
immediately apply to your life
or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I also want to
give a quick shout out
to Christophe, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and posting that fun picture
on Instagram that included the
little tiny temo on the side,
I really, really, really
appreciate your support.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(light dramatic music)
- I want us happy focused on
short-term money coming in
when creating a company because otherwise,
the company will die.
So, I think that a lot of
times, people think like,
creating a company is going to be fun.
I would say it's really not that fun.
Well, there are periods of fun
and there are periods of
where it is just awful.
And particularly, if you
oversee over a company,
you actually have a distillation
of all the worst problems
in the company.
So, there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right.
So, you only spend your time
on things that are going wrong
and there are things that are going wrong
that some other people can't take care of,
so you're like the worst.
You have a filter for the
crappiest problems in the company,
(laughing)
the most pernicious and painful problems.
So, I wouldn't say, it's,
I think you have to feel
quite compelled to do it
and have a fairly high pain threshold.
There's a friend of mine who
says like starting a company
is like staring at the
abyss and eating glass.
And there's some truth to that.
(audience laughing)
The staring into the abyss part
is that you're going
to be constantly facing
the extermination of the company,
cause most startups fail.
It's like 90% or 99% of startups fail.
So, that's the staring
into the abyss part.
You're constantly saying,
"If I don't get this right,
"the company will die."
Should be quite stressful.
And then the eating glass part is
you've got to do the problems,
you're going to work on the problems
that the company needs you to work on,
not the problems you want to work on.
And so, that's, you end
up working on problems
that you really wish
you weren't working on
and so, that's the eating glass part.
And that goes on for a long time.
- [Interviewer] So, how
you do you keep your focus
on the big picture when
you're constantly faced with,
"We could be out of business in a month?"
- Well, it's just a very small percentage
of mental energy that's
on the big picture.
Like, you generally know
where you're heading for
and the actual path is going to be
some sort of zig-zaggy
thing in that direction.
You try not to deviate
too far from the path
that you want to be on
but you're going to have
to do that to some degree.
But I don't want to diminish,
I think the probability is a good one
if the rules of an industry
are properly set up.
So, there's nothing
fundamentally wrong with profit.
In fact, profit just means
that people are paying you more
for whatever you're doing than
you're spending to create it.
That's a good thing.
(laughing)
And if that's not the case,
then you'll be out of
business and rightfully so.
You're not adding enough value.
- There's a latin expression,
which I think is great.
I love it, it was in a now very old movie
called The Dead Poet's Society,
but the line in the movie was
carpe diem, seize the day.
The opportunities are there
but you've got to reach out
and pick them up.
You've got to grab at 'em.
Some of you may have
already done that at the U
and your classes, in other
students that you met,
in your extracurricular
activities, but grab them.
Don't be afraid to make a mistake
because you know what you can
do if you grab the wrong one?
Drop it and pick up another one.
It's okay, seize the day.
I think back, of all of the luck,
but also the times that
were in front of me,
to seize the day.
I don't know what got me to
drop out of business school
and come to Microsoft.
My parents thought I was a whack job.
Neither one of them graduated college
and they thought this
was really a wild idea.
I was lucky, I seized the day.
Microsoft, one day some
guys fly in from IBM
and all of a sudden, we figure out
that we could actually
provide all the software
they need for this thing
that became the personal computer.
People, Bill, Paul, they had the wisdom
to seize the day when that
opportunity presented itself
and yet, when you think
of all the opportunities,
when I think back of all
the opportunities I've had,
the one that was most important
was an opportunity I got in 1969.
Sitting in my junior high school class,
I was in a public junior high,
not very stimulated at the time,
and over the loudspeaker they said
that a private high school in our area
that I'd never heard of
was giving scholarship tests that weekend.
I told my mother I wanted to take 'em,
she said, "That's fine as
long as you get a scholarship
"because we can't afford
to send you there."
But that's really where I got switched on.
Switched on in math,
switched on personally,
energized in a way that never,
never could be turned back.
And I'm very thankful
for that opportunity.
Yes, there's a lot of luck in opportunity
but there's a lot of seizing the day
and I encourage you all to
reach out and carpe diem,
really seize the opportunities
that are in front of you.
- I've been working, I've
been in business for 69 years,
since I was 12 and every time,
well, after the first
dozen or so businesses,
I realized that the only way to get ahead
was to do things differently
than the way it was being done.
And then I came to learn,
which I finally learned
at my ripe young age, that
if you do things differently,
success will follow you like your shadow
and you can't get rid of it.
So, that's what I did,
so people doubted me
because people just
didn't do what I would do.
It's a matter of finding out what it is
that an industry does and
identifying the opportunity
as to how to do it differently
and then being enough of a risk taker
to actually do it differently.
So, people doubted me
because nobody thought of
doing it the way that I did
and nobody had, they didn't have the,
they were satisfied with the status quo
and I'm never satisfied
with the status quo.